Jesus wait is that a real picture I
think it's a real photo
Twitter is already the best version of
itself you may not even like Twitter but
the best version of Twitter is Twitter
today's uh fun important content we're
going to be looking at some Mean Tweets
people that have uh said very mean
things about me
I guess we thought that uh I don't have
enough negativity in my life and myself
see Mr high so we're just gonna spend
some time uh reading some horrible
things people said about me now the
great thing is that there are so many
Mean Tweets about me and so many people
saying such horrible things but McKenna
you you compiled these tweets right the
mechanics Holly oh okay well Polly
McKenna together compiled these tweets
and I'm gonna assume that whatever these
tweets say it's really what they think
because they're picking the tweets that
resonate the most with them in a certain
way so
no pressure on them at all all right
let's go to the first tweet this is from
Miss met says geez imagine being Matt
Walsh it has to suck really McKenna wow
yeah it is it's a terrible thing I know
a beautiful wife successful in my career
six beautiful kids make more than enough
money to provide for a family of eight
it's a terrible thing it's a terrible
lot in life you would not want this in
your life at all so you're absolutely I
can't disagree with that Matt Walsh is
such a baby back shut the up
you stupid ass loser baby back is
that a thing is that a is that slang is
that see I'm so out of the loop that I
don't know you can make up slang when
you're talking to me about me and I
wouldn't know so I don't know did he
just make that up baby back baby
back baby back baby back baby back or is
that a thing that the kids say I don't I
don't I don't particularly know
thank you
I kind of like it it flows off the
tongue I might start using that I might
start calling people baby back
Matt Walsh looks like a muppet but a
muppet that was designed to make people
go what the happened to this Muppet
yeah you know I want to disagree with
that and I and I was about to I was
about to say I don't really go Muppet
you look like a muppet and I was about
to say that but then I remembered that
someone literally did make a muppet out
of me and it looked strikingly similar
and look I don't take that as a as an
insult some Muppets are quite attractive
you might say and so I don't think that
but some people might
what I hate most about Matt Walsh
proficiency aside has to be he
looks like you'd sit near him at a
brewery and think oh oh God I bet this
is drinking IPA and then he is
and then you think oh oh God I bet
he's gonna tell me about it and then he
does
he's right about you're right about the
first part definitely drinking the ipas
not the second uh I'm not the guy that's
going to strike up a conversation with
you at the bar I used to very much be
the guy that just sit alone at the bar
and not talk to anyone
just staring
silently and drinking the IPA yes that
that I'm that guy so you're wrong about
the the second part the first part
you're correct but also I don't
understand the whole thing oh I bet you
drink ipas like it's an insult it is
yeah I like beer that tastes good you
you caught me I don't think of Miss what
you think of miss you you got me is that
supposed I don't why is that an insult
IPA objectively just the best quality
beer you could find it's beer that
actually tastes like beer oh I bet
you're the kind of guy who enjoys when
you drink a beverage for it to taste
like it's supposed to taste
sure I guess I just think Matt Walsh is
too ugly to have opinions hmm I mean I
would make the argument that the uglier
you I mean you could make the argument
that the uglier you are the more your
opinions have some validity to them
because when you're too attractive you
know you you have a an easier path in
life less the path of less resistance
but like you can get by with being
stupid but if you're not saddled with
that burden then uh then you have to get
by on your wits and your intelligence so
that's my argument there I think that
because I'm ugly my opinions are even
more valid is that what he calls it all
right as you might know I'm uh I'm a
huge fan of our friends at genocello
genu sales products Sunspot brown spots
discoloration and even red inflamed
patches all disappear in front of your
very eyes and here's the genocell
amazing guarantee you'll see results on
day one for your money back if you want
to feel better about your own skin take
advantage of geniusol's most popular
package which now includes the Dark Spot
Corrector plus the classic genucel bags
and puffiness treatment and immediate
all at about 70 off so you can try the
best skin care in the world for yourself
completely risk-free it's simple go to
genyourself.com Walsh YT start looking
years even decades younger tomorrow say
goodbye to dark and liver spots bags and
puffiness under the eyes and crow's feet
at geniusell.com Walsh YT that's
geniusello.com Walsh YT all the leftists
I know are total smoke shows while every
single conservative Dude Looks Like a
sentient bag of wet hair
come on uh I if you think the most
conservatives look like a sentient bag
of wet hair okay whatever the leftists
you know are smoke shows do you mean
like smoke shows as in they look like
burn victims is that what you mean
because hey what leftists are you
looking at look get any antifa rally
okay look at any rally of trans
activists and where are the where are
the smoke shows like let's be realistic
about this I'm not saying that every
conservative is a is a is a 10 out of 10
on the physical attractive to scale but
let's be real here what you're telling
me is that you're blind and so then that
really mitigates the effectiveness of
the second part of the insult so just a
little tip Matt Walsh is an ugly person
I might agree with some of his takes but
he is unnecessarily hateful and goes out
of his way to be so so I'm really
noticing uh some themes with these Mean
Tweets is that they're all about how
ugly I am like I said I think we're
learning some things we're learning some
things about the folks that work here
and how they feel about me personally
unless it really is true that every mean
thing is said about me on Twitter is all
centered around how ugly I am is that
maybe that's true there hasn't been a
single that says
bad transpho racist that's like 99 of
them so what they did Holly McKenna they
said no no we're not going to do those
because that's not going to offend him
enough let's actually try to hurt his
feelings let's go for the ones that are
really going to get to him I see I
respect
you're both still fired but I respect it
I don't like to comment on people's
looks but Matt Walsh is so hideously
ugly wow they're supposed to be mean
tweets not just Matt Walsh is ugly
that's
that wasn't the bit that we agreed on
you know we had a we had a meeting where
we were pitching different ideas for
content and no one said hey let's do a
video where you spent 10 minutes reading
uh tweets about how ugly you are that
was not exactly how this idea was
presented originally I'm not saying I
would have said no to that idea but you
know let's be honest about it working on
a documentary about Matt Walsh it's
titled what is a cuck all right so
that's a little something different
you haven't heard the insult in a
while soy boy cook simp you're the
lowest of the low the person's name is
at born miserable so this person is
living up to their title usually when
you hear that word thrown around in the
past this is like that's a right-wing
insult and now it seems like the left
has tried to claim that insulted but
they got in a little bit late and nobody
uses it anymore and let's see did I skip
one I think I did but I'm doing this on
my phone so I can't even keep track of
the ones that I've looked at finally
it's gonna be so awesome when Matt
Walsh's wife finally divorces him and
writes a tell-all book about what a sick
twisted creepy angry dumb perverted
little micro fascist face is
I mean that's really threw it all in
there that's that's one long sentence a
little bit of it but you know I'll give
you credit it's a long sentence a lot of
words ignorant dog kissing
brainless hopeless uh but grammatically
it works and it's not really a run-on
sentence and I will give you
some credit for that
however
oh thank you well we're at the we're at
the end of the video now so
they used this earlier
I don't cry on camera that's when this
is over I want to go in a corner
somewhere and
and weep bitterly the only problem is
the common theme with leftist insults uh
is that they really
you know they just want is I I know
you're going to divorce you're in a
miserable marriage it's it's your
family's gonna fall apart like no I'm
I'm sorry to disappoint you uh but
actually happy marriage happy family uh
we're not all miserable lonely losers
like you that's a particular issue that
you have that doesn't apply to everyone
so I'm sorry to disappoint you but it
was a nice attempt anyway and I can
appreciate that all right so that's all
the horrible things people said about me
and I guess I'm gonna go now thanks
foreign
[Music]